OK, so we just looked at a way of
modifying a document using the save method. Now let's
look at an alternative way of updating documents. What
I want to introduce you to here, are two things.
One, the update command or method in pymongo it's
a method on collection objects. And the set operator. Let's
talk about update first. Update expects a query document
as its first parameter, and then as its second parameter,
it expects an update document. And that
update document specifies what operations MongoDB should perform
on the document matching this query. Now,
by default, update operates on just one document.
The first one it finds matching the query document. The semantics of set are, if
this document does not already contain the
fields specified here, then what should happen is
that field should be added with this value.
If the document already contains this field, then that
field will be updated to the value supplied.
Okay, now before I run this code, what I'd
like to do is introduce you to the
inverse operator for set, which is unset. Okay, so
these two pieces of code are almost exactly
the same. The only differences are here and here.
The semantics of unset are, for whatever document matches
this query, if it has the field specified here,
remove it. This value is ignored. Now, if this
document does not already have this field, then this
call has no effect. Okay, so now we've looked
at the set operator and the unset operator, and
their use with the update command. Now, let's go
and run these two programs. And see what their
effect is. But first, I want to query for this
document in the Mongo shell to look at its current state,
and then we can see how running those two programs changes
its current state. So I'm going to run a find one command
here. Now, this is exactly the same command as we
saw in the Python programs we were looking at. The only
difference is in the name. And the names are different merely
to match the conventions of the two different programming languages represented.
In this case, JavaScript because the language of the
Mongo Shell is JavaScript. And, in the other case,
Python, because we're using the Pymongo driver. Okay? So,
going to issue this query. And, I want to point out
that the Iso Code is in fact present. Now
let's run the unset example and then go back
to the Mongo shell and issue our query again.
Okay? And note that the iso country code has
disappeared because we just ran this command. Okay,
now let's run our set example. And again remember
this simply uses the set operator. Let's do
our query again in the Mongo shell and note
that the iso country code is now in
our document again. Okay, so now we've looked at
two different commands that allow us to modify documents.
The save command, and the update command. And we've
looked at two different operators being used in conjunction
with the update command. Okay, now I feel like it's
necessary before we move on to just give you a
heads up. It's really easy to forget to put an
operator here. Okay? If you issue your command this
way, what's going to happen is this entire document, the
document matching this query, will be replaced so that it
contains the underscore ID field and this field only. So,
essentially, the document will be composed entirely of a
single field. So, always take care to use update correctly.